Idiopathic adolescent acute neurodegeneration or IAAN
Nearly 90% of the country's children are  now dead survivors of the virus develop side-effects or what some are calling powers
Unexplained incidents involving surviving children continue to pour in from across the country. We now go live to president grace
I am speaking today as a parent we'll find a cure and save our children
If people hear this you're one of us if you're one of us come and find us
The government's afraid of the ones who live but we don't have to stay in the darkness
The only ones who could help us are us
We're ready for you
Soon there wouldn't be any kids anywhere
The government wasn't afraid of what happened to the ones that didn't make it
They were afraid of us
Because the ones that survived changed
Lu Bu are very rare among its the most powerful
We're going to a place where kids can live together on the outside the only people who would ever help us for us
Whatever happens don't stop
For their safety and yours, please turn over your children
I'm smart enough to know you're hiding something and you're smart enough to be hiding
I just want you to be afraid of me more that I try to control it
More damage that I do I can show you how to use your strengths the way they're meant to be used
We can fight back
We don't have to stay in darkness we've survived all of this
I will fight for all of us